Một câu quan thục tình Mỹ, ăn hiểu của bản đề chính trị đất tình.
Trính quyền tộc thống Mỹ đuán tròm có thể đang ấm thầm soạn thảo một lộ trình, chấm rất trình xử mới,
chỗ của quay nà với sự thầm ra của ngà. Theo các quán trực nà và Mỹ, kể hoạt vô 2 mi tạm điểm,
lấy cầm hình tư để sốt nửa bản ở giải gà ra mà Washington đã thuộc đẩy thành công trực đó.
Một tiên gian quá giấu cho biết, bản để sốt tập trung vào vốn trụ của chính,
hóa bình tự quay nà, bảo đầm ăn những chỗ của quay nà, câu chủ ăn những chỗ al và định hình quan hệ bà bên Mỹ ngà của quay nà trong từ lại,
đặc phía viên Mỹ sẽ biết có bản nơi giấm rất quá trình xây dựng kế hoạch và đã thảo lận nhiều lần với đặc phía viên ngà,
kỳwi and Dimitriac. Tôn này tại máy a Mỹ, ông biết có cũng chào đổi nổi dùng xơ bộ với cố vấn ăn nình của tổng thống của quay nà,
ông Rút Stem của Merope, theo Ajoz, nhà trắng cũng đang trình bị thông bảo khai quá để sốt,
người mùa số nước châu Âu, để nhận phản hồi. Huyện tổng thống của quay nà với lối với MSG cũng đang có chuyển công dù châu Âu,
bất đầu là hi lọc. Tại pháp và ngày Mỹ tạo thống như một tại tế bà nhà, ông nói đang tìm cách tích hoạch lại,
cho nó lực ngoại giao, nhằm kết thúc của xong đột lên quan tới tình hình trên sử. Giờ trước của quay nà cho biết,
các máy bay không người là nhà đã tấn công chung cửa thành phố khách kép, giọng sẵn là Mỹ chỉ thông mấy môt,
người trẻ lớn và lặng bệnh người bí thương hay mi hàng người phải sớt tạm. Tại nha,
sinh vài cross nú đã đặc vụ phần của Hóa Đốc để bảo đảm ạm tòa máy sau khi gây nhận vụ nổ.